and our government that's that big that
takes that much of your money that is
big enough and powerful enough to spy on
you to lie to you to target you is a
government that we ought not have in the
first place hi I'm Nick Gillespie with
Reason TV and today we're talking with
Senator Mike Lee a Republican from Utah
first one election in 2010 he's the
author of our lost constitution the
willful subversion of America's founding
document which is just out in paperback
and the founder of the article one
project which seeks to restore Congress
to the status of first among equals in
the federal government thanks for
talking to us thank you the article one
project which you announced earlier this
year seeks to restrain the powers of the
judicial branch but especially the
executive branch for those of us who are
not lawyers explain why Congress should
be top dog among three co-equal branches
of the federal government Congress
should be top dog within its own sphere
which is lawmaking right now it's not
and the idea isn't so much about taking
power away from the other branches as
much as it is putting the power that
involves lawmaking back in the hands of
Congress bad things happen when we
delegate out that power to the executive
branch and the judicial branch as we've
been doing for days yes so give a give a
couple of examples in which the
president overstepped his legitimate
powers or the and the Supreme Court did
the same okay so some of the best
examples of those are the most obvious
ones when the president decided to make
for recess appointments on January 4
2012 during a time when the Senate was
not in fact in recess right it was
unprecedented eventually the Supreme
Court got that one right mm-hmm it took
us a while to get there that was a
rather obvious excess and that was one
where the president was to blame there
are lots of other areas though where
there's too much power in the executive
branch and it's actually Congress's
fault right because Congress has stopped
being the lawmaker Congress instead of
passing laws to start of giving homework
assignments to executive branches
because they yeah they just say the
agencies you guys come up with the
regulations or the way these things will
be implemented sometimes what Congress
does instead of actually making a law
deciding how to address a problem
let's take clean air for example instead
of
Congress coming up with a comprehensive
system for pollution limits Congress
will instead perhaps pass a law that
says we shall have clean air and we
hereby delegate to the EPA the power to
create rules carrying the force of
federal law that will define what clean
air means that will define what
pollution is set acceptable pollution
limits prescribed penalties for
polluters and then by the way EPA will
have the power to enforce the laws that
it has already created now this turns
the EPA into a super legislature and
executive and that's a problem
especially because people at the EPA is
hardworking and as smart as they might
be they don't work for the people that
they don't ever stand for election now
your colleagues in the article one
project include people like Jeb horns
Hensarling Mia love Rand Paul Jeff Flake
others but they're all Republicans how
do we know this isn't just about the GOP
sticking it to a Democratic
administration it's it's not especially
because our plan my goal is eventually
to turn into a bipartisan thing we would
like to make enough of a case that
eventually we'll have Democrats who will
want to join us in this recognizing that
this is ultimately neither Republican or
democratic neither liberal nor
conservative this is just a good
governance sort of a thing most
importantly it's a constitutional thing
what are some of the ways in which a
george w bush or republican presidents
overstep their bounds i was concerned
when george w bush signed into law
legislation in the campaign finance
arena notwithstanding the fact that he
in signing it voiced significant
constitutional concerns and then said
we'll let the courts work out the
constitutional issues it's a different
kind of overreach but it's overreach
nonetheless it's overreach and under
each combined because presidents are
themselves independently accountable to
the constitution like every other
federal officer they're required to
swear an oath to uphold and protect and
defend the constitution what happened to
Congress why did it why did it become so
spineless in essence what happened was
that Congress starting during the New
Deal era created these big executive
branch agencies and started delegating
power initially Congress
of appeas'd itself by saying we're gonna
have the last word we're gonna put in a
provision of law of it yeah although
we're delegating all this legislative
power on X Y or Z to agency a B or C we
will give ourselves the power to veto
any regulation they come out with that
we don't like so even though the
agencies will be the real lawmakers will
have the last word that work that worked
well it was popular for about 50 years
we had hundreds of these legislative
veto provisions on the books and it made
Congress feel still like it was in
charge then the Supreme Court decided a
case called I NS V Chadha in the
mid-1980s they said that was
unconstitutional a lot of people thought
at that point that Congress would stop
delegating its lawmaking power it didn't
it got worse you see what happened was
Congress became addicted to this
practice because it made it so easy for
members of Congress to seek and obtain
their Holy Grail which is perpetual
re-election okay yeah and then there are
simultaneously they can take credit for
passing a good law but they're not
responsible for the the dirty details
all of the credit none of the blame
that's so rather so what are those
specific measures that you and your
colleagues in the article one project
and you talk about this in the book
anticipating it you know to real an
executive power and explain that the
content and the current status of the
act that you've put together the
regulations from the executive in need
of scrutiny act or the reins act like
you're reining things in what's going on
with the reins act is perhaps the single
most important feature or the the
definitely the the first step that ought
to be taken that could restore a lot to
separation of powers what the reins Act
says is that anytime you have an
executive branch agency making a new law
something that is in effect a new law
imposing obligations on the public
something that has a significant
economic cost attached to it as measured
by the OMB would that be a hundred
billion dollars in the economy so
similar to the regulation and that limit
for regulation that gets called for
higher scrutiny precisely precisely is
known as a major rule in regulatory
parlance the all new major rules would
have to be run back through Congress in
other words it's not a a veto where
Congress just says no you can't do it
but it
says this won't take effect unless
Congress affirmatively enacted into law
and then the president signs it what are
the odds of that passing anytime soon
how many sponsors things like that okay
it has passed the House each year every
year for about the four last four or
five years in a row we have yet to have
a straight up or down vote on it in the
United States Senate I am continually
but maybe if your party gains control of
the Senate you could actually engineer
that right oh wait yeah one of the
problems is that we do have a president
who wouldn't sign it right my hope is
that with the change in administration's
regardless of who the next president is
maybe there will be a a new mood
especially if there is a Republican
president who knows a libertarian
president perhaps Democrats in the House
Senate will be more eager to see this
for what it is which is a nonpartisan
issue you know they should be concerned
about this just from a separation of
power well and this is in the lost
Constitution you talked you know the
this the the reins Act the article 1
project I'll flow neatly from your book
what do voters have to do in order to
see this kind of change voters I think
and the first and foremost start
focusing on the fundamental structural
protections in the Constitution so in
order for the Bill of Rights to work in
order for any other substantive
protection in the Constitution to work
we have to have our structural
protections in place the vertical
protection we call federalism which
tells us to govern locally most of the
time except when it's unavoidably
national and recognized as national by
the Constitution and we have the
horizontal protection we call separation
of powers if voters Republicans
Democrats independents libertarians if
voters would all recognize that almost
every ailment we have in the federal
government is do in one way or another
to our neglect of federalism federalism
and separation of powers and if we would
make these constitutional terms part of
our national political discourse this
would revolutionize America you talk
about having you know that people should
talk to their friends about read the
Constitution talk about the Constitution
is that very likely yes it is likely
there have been times in the past where
that has happened where people were more
conversant in the constitution it was
part of the national political discourse
George Washington himself right after
the Constitution was drafted before it
was ratified predicted that this would
be the case and this is
something that he predicted would be the
great safety valve so it's a sonic
placement where it's like keeping up
with the kardashians and the
Constitution or something but this is I
know what you're seeking is you know for
us to actually take take our political
documents seriously yeah yeah to
popularize it and this book tells the
stories behind it in a way that makes it
familiar yeah and which is something I
should point out the book is I mean it's
filled with stories it is not a law
lecture or you know a set of regulations
so it's it's quite impressive and you
kind of anticipate it'll a being you
read about Alexander Hamilton a lot and
you you kind of got there before the the
hit Broadway musical even so you know as
I recall it hit Broadway right about the
time that the hardcover version of my
book was hitting and I remember thinking
gosh there are some parallels here
because I talk a lot about Hamilton in
my book one of the reasons why I think
that play is so popular is that people
are curious about the founding
generation they instinctively know that
those guys did something right
they had something right it was figure
I'm curiosity about the Constitution
your party the presumptive nominee is
Donald Trump who seems to have very
little knowledge of the Constitution I
mean it doesn't seem like he's spent a
lot of time studying it or he could pick
it out of a lineup of other founding
documents he also seems from the way he
talks that he would be very in favor of
enlarging executive power immensely
Hillary Clinton is part of the Obama
administration which has overstepped its
bounds time and time again who do you
think would be worse in terms of you
know making a really imperial presidency
that is a little bit difficult to
predict accurately and completely
because we don't know entirely how
someone would behave and as president
until they're actually in office that is
always the case I will say this though I
have a presumption there's a presumption
that I think is fair to make these days
that almost any president unless that
president is decisively different and
unless that candidate announces an
intention to be different if elected you
have to assume that that president will
pay little heed to federalism or
separation of powers that they will lean
toward being autocratic lean toward
consolidating more power and this is
even true with Obama who was elected
partly because he said you know the Bush
administration had gone too far and
throwing its weight around making
unilateral decisions I'm a
constitutional law professor I'll be
different and then he expanded extended
and enlarged many of the same problem
programs right hope and change uh well
you know we there's still 20/20 right
you've refused to endorse Trump so far
and you recently denounced his claims
that Ted Cruz's father was involved in
the assassination of the Kennedy
assassination as part of the reason what
are the other reasons you're reluctant
to endorse Trump and is there anything
that he can do to win your vote or your
endorsement and if not break some news
right now in looking for a presidential
candidate who could win my support I'm
always looking for someone who will say
I will restore federalism and separation
of powers here's what I will do to do
that here's my formula I'll start with a
reins Act I'll push the separation of
powers Restoration Act getting rid of
so-called Chevron deference in the
courts
I will push power back to the states I
will veto anything that transgresses my
more limited interpretation of the
Commerce Clause and/or of the spending
clause and here's where I think we've
deviated from our interpretation so it
was participating you're endorsing Gary
Johnson right now or you're just not
going to write anybody for president I'm
looking for a candidate who will do that
and I'll do everything I can to find and
support candidates who will do that
final question you were part I mean
you're one of the poster boys of the Tea
Party you know because you you know very
clearly articulated the idea of the
government is spending too much it's
doing too much we have to stop and start
reducing that is the Tea Party has spent
force in American politics or what has
happened to it because it meant you know
it seems like it was a long time ago
that anybody was talking about that both
Trump and Hillary Clinton in their
budgets that they announced there they
increased spending from over 22 percent
of GDP as a percentage of GDP to even
higher tea party does it still matter
nobody's sure what the term Tea Party
means one of the problems and is is that
nobody controls the brand name
tea party another problem is nobody can
really agree on what it is what it meant
it was a term that people came to
associate with the grassroots
conservative political phenomenon that
started manifesting itself arguably in
2008 at least by 2009 that that swept a
lot of people into the Senate and House
elections in 2010 and 2012 look that
phenomenon is still out there
people tend not to refer to it as the
Tea Party movement anymore I I tend to
call myself a constitutional
conservative I think that's just what
best describes me more than any other
single label but the sentiments are
still out there
it's just the they go by different names
do you worry at all that the Republican
Party is is is dying is the future of
the Republican Party to become more
libertarian in terms of reducing the
size scope and spending of government I
think the future of the Republican Party
depends on its ability to simplify to
identify a concise mission statement and
here's where constitutional
conservatives and libertarians can merge
their efforts to help move the
Republican Party or move something in
that direction whether it's the
Republican Party or just the
conservative movement as a whole to move
the country in the right direction
because constitutional conservatives and
libertarians both understand we've got
to simplify the federal government is
too complex it's doing too many things
it was never intended to do and our
government that's that big that takes
that much of your money that is big
enough and powerful enough to spy on you
to lie to you to target you is a
government that we ought not have in the
first place so III think there's a lot
of good that conservatives
constitutional conservatives and
libertarians can do if we can steer the
ship in the right direction simply by
simplifying what we're doing simplifying
the whole purpose of the federal
government all right well we will leave
it there the book is the lost
Constitution it is out in paperback now
we've been talking with Senator Mike Lee
of Utah he's a Republican and he's
heading up something called the art
one project that would radically alter
and revise what government does senator
thanks for talking to us thank you for
reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie